long before Kim Jong hoon became the
go-to tyrants for five-star absurdity
there was another dictator on the Block
Muammar al-gaddafi ruled Libya for 42
years with an iron fist wrapped in a
sequined glove so garish it would put
Liberace to shame his flamboyant reign
was famous for its absurdity for every
headline relating to his terrorist
activities there were maybe a dozen more
about his plastic surgery addiction or
his all-female bodyguard troop by the
time Gaddafi was overthrown in 2011 he
was less feared than he was simply
mocked but behind the monstrous vanity
lay a man who is simply a monster
raping Gaddafi's Libya it was
institutionalized mass executions were
broadcast on TV dissidents were executed
and their bodies were kept in freezers
for the self-styled king of all kings to
visit at his leisure but such depraved
behavior it wasn't created in a vacuum
it was only thanks to Libya's tortured
history that Gaddafi was able to imprint
his psychosis on his nation today on bio
graphics were exploring the life of the
Mad Dog of the Middle East
[Music]
most historians of Gaddafi start at the
obvious place the sweltering June day in
1942 when he was born in a nomads tent
near the dusty fishing village of sir
Tay but to really understand Gaddafi you
have to go back further all the way back
to September the 28th to 1911 that's the
day Italian warships appeared off the
coast of Tripoli it was the beginning of
the Italian occupation and the beginning
of Libya's very own reign of terror for
the next few decades Libya was not a
nice place to be anything other than a
pureblood Italian natives were worked to
death in squalid labor camps while
resistance fighters were brutally
executed in public but the whole affair
only ended when the Allies booted Italy
from North Africa in 1943 by that point
over a third of all Libyans had been
murdered by the colonizers if Gaddafi
was cruel it's because he was born into
a world where cruelty was the only
currency with British help King Idris of
Cyrenaica seized power in 1951 joining
the three colonies of Italian Libya into
modern Libya and ushering in a period of
peace not the younger dha'fi had it easy
his family were poor veterans
he lived in a tent his only formal
schooling was meant to be learning the
Koran it's only because he showed
promise that he was sent on to basic
school presumably his family hopes that
he was destined for greater things
spoiler alert that's what we call
foreshadowing while young Gaddafi was at
school scraping his knees and carving
his name into desks Libya was sinking
into a mire of poverty King Idris was
selling land to the US Army in return
for cash in his family's pockets which
was as popular as you would expect with
the population while this sort of naked
corruption was humiliating for ordinary
Libyans it was just a symptom of the
broader malaise gripping the Arab world
with culture in decline and the rich
looting their countries the average Arab
was looking for a champion they were
looking for someone to make them feel
proud again and this is where Nasser
enters the picture Colonel Gamal Abdel
Nasser is a man who honestly could fill
a dozen of these videos all by himself
the new ruler of Egypt following a
bloodless coup in 1950
- he was the guy about to light the
spark of Arab nationalism and send it
exploding across the region in June 1956
when he finally did that furious with
the British military presence in his
nation and angry at the new State of
Israel on his borders he nationalized
the British owned Suez Canal so well the
British joined forces with France and
Israel meant invaded triggering the Suez
Crisis the whole Suez Crisis is beyond
our scope here so let's just skip ahead
to the ending Israel France and Britain
they lost the canal now the basic reason
they lost the canal is pretty much
because the u.s. started yelling at them
and they basically said get out now you
idiot so you're going to set off World
War 3 but that is certainly not how the
Arab world saw it overnight NASA became
a sensation combined with his
working-class roots his poverty
reduction programs and his desire for
Arab unity he became the hero to
millions of people among those newly
inspired people was teenage Gaddafi
still in school he was watching the Suez
Crisis unfold with a sort of mixture of
ore and excitement the apparents
probably felt watching the moon landing
that's with so many others NASA's
boldness his ambition it lit a fire in
Gaddafi's soul before the suez crisis
was over he'd been expelled from school
for political agitation but if you think
a simple expulsion is gonna halt
Gaddafi's new ambition to be the Libyan
NASA well you're in for a big surprise
[Music]
five years after his expulsion young
Gaddafi managed to finagle his way into
the military academy in Benghazi he did
this for the express reason of staging
and Nasser a coup seriously he even
brought a loyal group of school friends
along with him all of him donned uniform
for the very first time on the
understanding that they'd soon be
overthrowing the government however this
was not to happen just yet for eight
years Qaddafi and his co-conspirators
did nothing more than slowly rise up the
army ranks Gaddafi was made a captain
and he was briefly trained in the UK he
met the American ambassador who astutely
noted that the young soldiers
intelligence was only matched by his
extraordinary emotional instability by
1963 Gaddafi had established a secret
Free Officers Society in the army
modeled after nasa's old coup planning
team by 1965 it had expanded its
membership far beyond his childhood
friends becoming the army club to join
now convinced destiny was on his side
Gaddafi simply needed a sign that Libya
was ready for an uprising and in 1967 it
got it On June the 5th long simmering
tensions between Israel and its Arab
neighbors finally reached boiling points
the resulting six-day war saw Israel
wiped the floor with Egypt Syria and
Jordan while barely even breaking a
sweat for our story though it was the
reaction in Libya that really mattered
angered at such epic Arab humiliation
the populace rioted it was the first
major sign of dissent against addresses
rule until now Libyans had been almost
uniquely undemonstrative in the Arab
world forget a cease free officers this
was the sign that been looking for in
August 1969 King Idris made the fateful
decision to go to Turkey for medical
treatments while he was out of the
country the Free Officers they quietly
seized control when Libya awoke on
September the 1st it was to a new regime
the monarchy had been toppled in a
bloodless coup and the Free Officers now
ruled via the Revolutionary Command
Council with Gaddafi at its chair at age
just 27 the meadow and boy born in a
tent became the de facto ruler of Libya
so given what we know about Gaddafi well
how was the coup received at the time
surprisingly it was actually received
rather well most Libyans they embraced
it while Idris had been popular with his
clan
most others felt his rule had been weak
and pretty ineffective and Gaddafi
he wasn't just being vain calling
himself the Libyan NASA ordinary Libyans
really were crying out for a pan-arab
champion to restore their pride and drag
them into the modern world even on the
international scene their reaction was
mostly warm Henry Kissinger was willing
to accept Gaddafi's insistence that the
u.s. abandon its Libyan bases on the
basis that the new leader was at least
an anti-communist in fact the only group
who turned out to be unhappy with the
idea of a Gaddafi led coup were the Free
Officers themselves who tried to stage
yet another coup in December to replace
Gaddafi but they were not successful and
they were very quickly crushed as the
Sun dawned on a new decade it was on a
Libya that was now totally under
Gaddafi's control the 1970s saw Libya
get off to a fresh start there was if
not exactly good then not utterly
terrible following NASA's lead the now
Colonel Gaddafi nationalized key assets
like petroleum production he made
education free and he distributed money
to the poor also like his hero Gaddafi
expelled the Jews along with all
remaining descendents of the Italian
colonists it's here that we get our
first glimpse of the man the Qaddafi
would become for the new Libyan leader
it wasn't enough that the Italians
simply left they had to be humiliated as
well he forced all those going into
exile to dig up the corpses of their
dead from the graveyards and take them
with them that very literal caravan of
death must have been a chilling sight
however this was all relatively small
potatoes the outside world paid little
attention to Libya even the Arab
students that all changed on September
28 1970 that was the day that a massive
heart attack felled Gamal Abdel Nasser
the master he was suddenly gone it was a
tough time for the Arab world probably
made tougher by Gaddafi's loud
insistence that he was NASA's errands
would lead them all from now on while
the Middle East mourned its hero the
Libyan upstart began pulling all sorts
of tricks from starting a war with Chad
to getting thousands of Libyan youths to
storm the border with Egypt waving
petitions inked in their own blood
demanding the unit
occasion of Libya in Egypt now as mad as
this all was there was still a chance at
this stage that Gaddafi might end up
being okay he'd made some reforms and
had used the money from the nationalized
petroleum to bring clean drinking water
in irrigation ditches to the pneumatic
populace yet the clues to his future
madness was still there if he knew where
to look and that place was Gaddafi's
green book released in 1974 the green
book remains work like no other it's an
explanation of Gaddafi's political
philosophy it's a he D mix of utopianism
Arab nationalism Islamism socialism
tribal values and a great huge dollop of
xenophobia but it's all thrown together
in a way that doesn't really make any
sense that may be why when Gaddafi
declared Libya the Green books
prophesized utopian governments the
great drama Harry yarn in 1977 only
Burkina Faso ever seemed enthusiastic
the rest of the Arab world simply
shrugged well almost
Gaddafi's green book prophesized that
other Arab powers would be so jealous of
the jamahiriya
that they would try to destroy it so in
July of 1977 he attacked Egypt first
before they could attack him I mean it
turns out Egypt never intended to attack
but now they were in this war and they
were damned if they were gonna lose it
500 dead later the world had a very good
indication that Gaddafi's jamahiriya
did not intend to play nice
[Music]
by the end of the 1970s it was clear
which way the winds were blowing
frustrated by the end of his dreams of
becoming the next NASA Gaddafi instead
settled for becoming notorious on his
own insane terms inside Libya this meant
a return to the repression of the
Italian era only with a weirdness that
was specifically unique to Gaddafi
cinemas music concerts and football
matches they were all banned followed by
anywhere else where people could plot
against the regime music was designated
Western imperialism and a great bonfire
of musical instruments burned in Tripoli
Central Square on the economic fronts
rampant corruption led to supermarkets
so empty that there were frequent deadly
food riots not that you could complain
of course because complaining then she
would become another victim in the mass
executions broadcast day and night on
public TV Gaddafi may have expelled the
Italian colonizers but he kept the
cruelest of their methods outside Libya
this was when Gaddafi began throwing
money at every extremist group on the
planet semtex went to the IRA weapons to
the Black Panthers and certainly money
to the ANC and yes that is the same ANC
that was led by Nelson della who at that
point was sitting in prison and do
remember this because it's going to be
important a bit later
so as 1981 shuddered interview Libya had
basically gone mad
the death toll of the ongoing war in
Chad was brutalizing the whole society
now also crumbling under a British led
economic embargo it was around this time
that Gaddafi first appeared on American
screens when US warships were forced to
shoot down two Libyan Jets over the Gulf
of 30 it was the first military clash
between America and an Arab power in
modern times and as you already know it
was not the last fast becoming an
international pariah Gaddafi doubled
down in the early 1980s he made a public
speech in which he called Libyans living
abroad stray dogs who would be hunted
down he also promised to bring chaos to
Europe a promise that he quickly
fulfilled now listen it would take the
rest of our time here today to give you
a running timeline of all of Gaddafi's
atrocities over the next few years let's
just say that they were numerous and
they were shocking highlights or maybe a
lowlights real my got something like
this April 1984 a sub
machine gun fires out of the window of
the Libyan embassy in London injuring
eleven anti-qadhafi protesters and
killing 25 year old police women Yvonne
Fletcher December 1985 Arab terrorists
funded by Libya launched simultaneous
gun attacks on Rome and Vienna airports
killing 19 and wounding 138 their
targets Jewish passengers April 1986
Libyan intelligence bombs a West Berlin
nightclub frequented by US soldiers two
soldiers and a Turkish civilian died on
nearly 230 are injured now it was this
last one that finally made the
international community take action
faced with dead American soldiers Ronald
Reagan authorized a bombing run on
Tripoli intended to take out Gaddafi
himself just days after that bomb went
off in Berlin American Jets streaked
across the pale blue Libyan skies
raining missiles on to the capital in
his compound mad dog Gaddafi was shaken
to life by an enormous explosion
staggering outside he supposedly founds
the bomb crater
that had been meant for him near that
crater lay the torn and bloodied body of
his adopted daughter the American bombs
may have failed in their goal of killing
the dictator but they at least seemed to
shake him to his senses the attacks on
Europe faltered in 1987 Gaddafi
officially ended the war in chat in 1988
he even mimicked Gorbachev's Petrus
troika reforms in the Soviet Union
allowing capitalism back into Libya and
personally standing atop a bulldozer
that smashed down the wall of a jail in
Tripoli freeing hundreds of political
prisoners at the time it looked like a
cynical ploy for winning back the hearts
of a population that had abused for so
long today though we know that the Mad
Dog was likely just playing for time
shortly after 6:00 p.m. on December the
21st that year Pan Am flight 103 took
off from Heathrow Airport
if flew upwards over Britain until it
reached the skies above the village of
Lockerbie Scotland there it disappeared
from radar screens when a control tower
tried to signal it only silence returns
we all know what happens at two minutes
past 7:00 a Libyan bomb exploded in the
hold of Pan Am 103 killing all 259
people on board flaming wreckage then
crashed down into Lockerbie killing a
further
and people in the aftermath of the
bombing it took an international
investigation two years to pin the blame
on Libya by that time Gaddafi's agents
had already downed another aircraft the
French operated UTA flight 772 which
exploded over Niger in 1989 death toll
170 people in 1992 the UN instigated a
harsh sanctions regime against Tripoli
this was the beginning of Gaddafi's
total isolation from the world if
Gaddafi had begun 1988 trying to emulate
the reformist zeal of Gorbachev he
entered the 1990s an isolated madman no
longer caring about what the world
thought of him it's around this time
that some of the darkest characteristics
of the mad dog began to emerge there are
tales of Secrets soundproof chambers
built into public buildings across
Tripoli if Gaddafi happened to be
visiting and saw a girly like she would
be slipped away and locked in these
rooms and he was ready to come and rape
her those who disappointed in that be
never heard from again
those who he likes might become part of
his all-female bodyguard retinue then
there were the young boys they were all
underage and all pretty they were kept
caged beneath his compounds and became
known euphemistically as the services
group a gang of child sex slaves The
Dictator could use whenever he wanted
finally there are the tales of the
freezers after the 2011 revolution a
group of ice rooms were discovered below
Gaddafi's palace inside each one lay
some rival who'd been killed on the Mad
Dogs orders some had been there for over
25 years it said that Gaddafi would
often come down there in the night and
touch their frozen corpses to be
reminded again there was an appearance
he wanted to feel the godlike power he
had over life and death these tales
though dead anything begin to scratch
the surface of the regime's horrors in
the 1990s
there's the day in 1996 when gods walked
into the Abu Salim political prison in
Tripoli dropped grenades into the cells
and killed 1270 men or the extreme
methods used to crack down on those who
began a tribal rebellion against his
rule in 1993 all the way the sanctions
bit so hard that speculating in water
became punishable by death all in all
the beer in the 1990s was just as bad a
as it was during the Italian occupation
perhaps even greater yet Gaddafi still
retained one unlikely friend learn that
mention of Nelson Mandela that we talked
about a few minutes ago
well now free Mandela spent most of the
90s trying to talk his one-time sponsor
into turning over the Lockerbie bombers
in 1999 the South African statesman
managed to extract both the promise to
do just that from Gaddafi and an apology
for the murder of Yvonne Fletcher back
in 1984 but it would be a world-changing
event that finally brought Gadhafi in
from the cold in the aftermath of 9/11
he became the first Arab leader to offer
both condolences and practical military
support to the USA suddenly in this
crazy new war on terror era Mad Dog
Gaddafi didn't seem to be such a bad guy
after all for the relatives of Gaddafi's
many victims the naughties were like
falling through the looking-glass
after Libya paid reparations to the
Lockerbie families the UN lifted its
sanctions then in 2004 Gaddafi suddenly
announced Libya was giving up all of its
chemical and biological weapons as a
reward both the George Bush and Tony
Blair governments began encouraging
business investment in Libya
the UK's mi6 even kidnapped the families
of two Libyan dissidents from Bangkok
and handed them over to Tripoli with a
note saying thank you this new
international phase for Gaddafi was
marked by him formally turning his back
on the Arab world in a public speech she
begged God to help keep the Arabs out of
Libya it seems this if he couldn't be
the Nasser of the Arabs then Gaddafi
would settle for being the NASA of
another people from the mid-2000s on
Gaddafi began laying the grounds for his
final quixotic dream a United States of
Africa this Africa would have one
passport one external border one army
and one ruler and you can probably guess
who he thought was right for the job
most African leaders unsurprisingly
dismissed the Mad Dogs latest fantasy
but not all in 2008 Gaddafi managed to
convince over 200 African kings and
tribal chiefs to crown him the king of
kings of all of Africa it was classic
Gaddafi pageantry but it did have
immediate consequences as
show of goodwill he threw Libya's
borders open to all Africans the result
was four and a half million Arab and
Muslim Libyans resentfully being forced
to share their country with a million
and a half Christian Africans while the
United States of Africa never went
anywhere the decade ended with Libya on
its best international footing since
1969 in 2009 Gaddafi even managed to use
his diplomatic clout to have the
Lockerbie bomber freed on compassionate
grounds all in all things were looking
up for the monster of Margaret he was
the longest-serving non-royal leader on
earth he had friends in Europe and
America the petrol money was pouring in
Gaddafi in 2010 looked unstoppable and
he might have been were in not for an
anonymous tunisian street vendor named
Mohamed Bouazizi
on December the 17th 2010 boys easy set
himself on fire to protest his
harassment by Tunisian authorities he
died of his wounds a couple of weeks
later but his suicide led to large-scale
protests that forced Tunisian autocratic
ruler from power the Arab Spring it had
arrived and it was about to hit Libya
like a hurricane
you might remember what happened next
Gaddafi was so sure as people loved him
that he was caught completely on the
backfoot when the country exploded in
revolt on February the 15th 2011
Benghazi fell and then the rest of the
East
finally aware of what was happening
Gaddafi dropped the mask of moderation
he'd worn since 9/11 the Mad Dog he came
roaring back and he was hungry for blood
as the world watched on the libyan army
began rolling towards benghazi those
inside were trapped barring an impending
massacre NATO stepped in a no-fly zone
quickly turned into bombing runs against
Gaddafi's units with Western airpower
now on their side the rebels broke out
of Benghazi and pushed West in no time
at all Gaddafi's forces were in retreat
the resulting civil war lasted 8 months
and killed somewhere in the region of
20,000 people in its end days the world
witnessed all of Gaddafi's worst
impulses he ordered the starvation of
Misrata in a horrifying siege his
jailers tortured prisoners to death his
soldiers were given orders to rape
civilians with Qaddafi he simply
couldn't counter NATO's airpower by the
end of the summer he was hiding insert a
the one time fishing village had been
born outside which
been transformed by four decades of his
patronage into a bustling city on
October the 20th 2011 rebel fighters
finally over Anton's defenses Gaddafi
was found hiding in a storm drain his
flamboyant clothes soaked with blood and
excrement surrounded by rubbish and
cowering like a rat sadly and Libya
cruelty still remain the currency as
Gaddafi whimpers what's this my sons
what are you doing he was surrounded by
a jeering crowd one soldier took his
bayonet and sodomized the dictator with
it slicing his insides open as phones
were waved to record his last moments
gunshots rang out the ground panicked
the images went blurry when they finally
refocused Gaddafi was dead nothing more
than a bloodied corpse in the back of a
truck the first and last king of all
Africa was no more today some seven
years after Gaddafi's unceremonious
execution Libya is a mess of tribal
conflicts and deadly instability there
are at least five groups in control of
swaths of the country on top of
countless militias over 10,000 people
have died since the post Gadhafi
settlement collapsed in 2014 making it
one of the worst wars currently raging
in the ends perhaps all Gaddafi really
did was hold his country back for a
nation forged in the cruelty of the
Italian occupation the cruelty of the
Gaddafi regime that only naturally to
the cruelty of today's conflict may be
under a different leader Libya could
have been something more as with so much
in history we will never know so I
really hope you found that video
interesting if you did please do hit
that thumbs up button below and don't
forget to subscribe we've got brand new
videos just like this twice a week also
do check out brilliance you'll find a
link to them in the description below
and thank you for watching
you
[Music]